[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires avec une
semaine de retour à la normale dans les
cinémas d'abord qui reprennent leurs
activités
et puis également les sports collectifs
qui sont à nouveau autorisées la france
retrouve donc son rythme de croisière
les enfants tous les enfants donc
retrouvé le chemin de l'école
le président l'avait annoncé le retour
des élèves est maintenant obligatoire
dans tout le pays
les règles sanitaires ont été allégées
mais reste à trouver la bonne
organisation
la reprise est plutôt sereine du côté
des pas ni vous allez le voir en haute
savoie comme l'ont constaté les équipes
de 8 mont blanc sur place
écoutez les témoignages c'est un
soulagement c'est aussi pour dire au
revoir à l'école je pense il risque deux
semaines donc voilà c'est plus pour dire
à son maître
l'année prochaine c'est un changement de
classe voilà c'est c'est bien je suis
pas d'accord pour qu'il est trop
d'enfants dans la classe ma fille est
aussi l es l et au cpa la six ans et
j'ai peur pour elle aussi surtout pour
elle c'était bien aujourd'hui
bah on a fait les chiffres n'a fait
naître on a fait les mathématiques c'est
mieux qu'une interruption global de six
mois et donc donc non non c'est bien ils
ont besoin de se resociabiliser on est
content pour eux et pour nous on a vu ce
matin en arrivant que c'était bien gérée
au niveau du flux au niveau de fermeture
de gris entre chaque classe que tout de
suite il se laver les mains au gel donc
pose ici ça commence comme ça c'est que
l'intérieur c'est pareil elle a été un
peu comme s'ils étaient une vision les
le côté social on n'en a pas trop manqué
mais il était très heureux de reprendre
le chemin de l'école pour voir ses
copains de classe mains en voyant son
sac d'école il m'a réclamé plusieurs
fois de vouloir retourner à l'école
après c'est pas un fond du décor je
pense comme son papa mais maintenant je
pense qu'il est content il était content
d'y aller il ya pas eu de pleurs tout
s'est bien passé
dans ce contexte les sports collectifs
ont aussi repris les fans de ballon rond
peuvent à nouveau réhausser les crampons
et pratiquer leur sport notamment en
salle les équipes de via mirabel se sont
rendus à owni en moselle dans une salle
de five le five et bien c'est le foot à
regardez le reportage dans l'armoire
depuis de très longues semaines les
crampons des footballeurs amateurs sont
désormais de retour sur les terrains
maillot de metz ou de l'équipe de france
sur le dos ils étaient nombreux à fouler
les pelouses synthétiques du five de
mehsud
dès la réouverture une reprise
compliquée pour certains mais qu'importe
le plaisir d'être réunies et de pouvoir
dribbler après une attente interminable
est bel et bien présent on est tous
contents de reprendre depuis le temps
qu'on attendait ça ça fait quatre mois
qu'on n'a pas touché le ballon donc
ouais ça fait plaisir on est impatient
je pense qu'on a un peu perdu en termes
techniques mais physique le confinement
un peu aidé quand même ça devrait aller
on retrouve vite les sensations après on
sent quand même que physiquement on a
cessé difficile
il fait chaud on a pris l'habitude de
courir mais bon voilà on est venu pour
se ressaisir pour se retrouver pour
jouer une petite heure en plus sous
forme de tournois donc on a le temps de
se reposer donc c'est sport le plus
populaire en nombre de licenciés
le football s'est mis en veille depuis
l'arrêt des championnats début mars
alors forcément du côté de la direction
on également heureux de pouvoir à
nouveau accueillir les joueurs et ce en
toute sécurité
on a eu un protocole très strict à
suivre donc c'est un petit peu comme
partout vous pouvez le voir on a dû
mettre des distances de sécurité vers la
caisse du gel hydroalcoolique un peu
partout dans le centre
on essaye de
de respecter les distances de sécurité
au maximum
donc les clients pour l'instant se plie
bien au protocole on va voir par la
suite que ce que ça donne si le plaisir
de retrouver le terrain est avant tout
sportif
il est également économique pour les
dirigeants des complexes de foot en
salle
après plus de trois mois sans aucune
rentrée d'argent tous espèrent relancer
la machine au plus vite
voilà nous allons à présent dans ce
grand jt des territoires dans les vosges
avec une méthode pour tout désinfecter
vous savez que c'est important après
cette crise sanitaire
cette méthode est inspiré par les
suisses et avec le déconfinement et la
réouverture des commerces la
désinfection à l'ozone fait son chemin
c'est une méthode qui a été adapté
depuis un mois par une société de
nettoyage de gérardmer elle s'appelle
net services et cela représente déjà la
moitié de son activité les explications
avec nos confrères de via vosges sur
place avec le déconfinement la
désinfection à l'ozone fait son chemin
une méthode très utilisée en suisse
adoptée depuis un mois par une société
de nettoyage de gérardmer et cela
représente déjà la moitié de son
activité avec la réouverture des
restaurants etc
là cette semaine la semaine prochaine on
va commencer à faire pas mal d'heures de
locaux et de commerce / gérardmer la
désinfection à l'ozone est un gaz connu
aussi sous le nom de trilles oxygène
permet de se passer de produits
chimiques mais nocifs pour les
organismes vivants une fois le
générateur posé il faut quitter la pièce
le temps du traitement francs en
arrivant dans une pièce on essaye de
passer l'appareil zone au milieu de la
pièce afin que les particules puisse
aller vraiment partout c'est à dire
aussi bien sur les ordinateurs dans les
tiroirs parce que l'ozone l'occident les
tiroirs comptez une heure et demie de
traitement pour 70 m² est suivie d'un
temps de pause équivalent et 2,30 à 140
euros hors taxes le coût du nettoyage
selon la surface
les virus et bactéries n'y résiste pas
l'ozone et domine aussi la poussière le
pollen et poêles d'amis
où les acariens préalablement
l'entreprise à désinfecter les points de
contact avec cette fois-ci de l'ozone
est en fait j'appuie justifier ensuite
reçu et là c'est 100% désinfecter on met
dans ses petits récipients on met de
l'eau dedans il ya des électrodes
diamant 6 a pas d électro diamant qui
ont transformé donc c'est tout là en
nous aux zones et la méthode à l'ozone
est certifié elle fait ses preuves avec
la réouverture des différents commerces
d'ailleurs pour répondre à la demande la
petite entreprise devrait bientôt passer
de trois à quatre salariés
voilà l'été est souvent la saison des
mariages
et oui mais avec le confinement est bien
tout a été bousculée annulé la plupart
du temps dans l'aube c'est même devenu
un vrai casse tête pour les nombreux
couples
certains ont même dû reporter les
cérémonies à l'année prochaine pour les
plus chanceux toutes les mesures
sanitaires doivent être respectés et
donc le port du masque est obligatoire
ce qui est pas très romantique comme le
montre ce reportage de canal 32 sur
place dans l'aube
sabine devait sceller sa nouvelle union
lors de son mariage le 6 juin m son
traiteur s'est déclaré en faillite
elle a préféré annuler la cérémonie
grâce aux réseaux sociaux elle a trouvé
d'autres couples qui ont subi la même
mésaventure ne peut pas rembourser nos
acomptes versés
c'est compliqué ça fait un sacré trou
dans le budget donc on est environ une
quinzaine de couples à s'être réunis et
au niveau pénal ça a été classée sans
suite
donc on a lancé nos protections
juridiques qui se sont qui s'occupe du
sujet autre sujet de préoccupation
réorganiser le mariage tout en tenant
compte du coc vide
sabine se dit chanceuse car espère avoir
trouvé une solution pour début septembre
on est dehors et mange de loudes et tour
est qu'on a récupéré tout coordonné à
nouveau et ne serait-ce que ma fille qui
sera mon témoin de mariage qui
travaillaient à l'hôpital de strasbourg
et qui n'est pas sûr d'avoir son
week-end pour mon mariage
sabine a retrouvé une envie de choisir
un autre traiteur et des solutions
alternatives
quand est ce que tu te maries on attend
encore cette question là et j'ai pas de
date
c'est ça c'est surtout ça sociation
salif et traiteur église mère ça devient
très compliqué ingrid devait se marier
le 30 mai ce jour là cette aide
soignante intervenait au service
réanimation de l'hôpital de troyes
après un an et demi de préparation et
malgré l'envoi des faire-part elle a dû
tout annuler sans nouvelle date en bus
pour l'année à venir ça va être très
compliqué pour celui qui veut se marier
déjà pour trouver une salle celle qu'on
avait et bat malheureusement remplit
déjà jusqu'au 31 mai de l'année
prochaine
après c'est sûr listes d'attentes j'ai
tellement rêvé ce mariage la robe la
musique le gâteau tard
et dans ce couple là en fait tout a
dégringolé en fait tic rompu dans
l'incertitude
et pour ne pas se dire oui avec un
masque sur le visage ce couple a lui
aussi annulé son mariage prévu le 1er
août il a pu in extremis réservé une des
rares journées restantes pour l'été
prochain
j'ai appris le prêtre pendant mes
vacances fin avril et s'il pouvait
encore faire des mais s'ils savaient pas
du coup nous a conseillé d'annuler en
fait et marié de 2020 avait déjà tous
réservés en 2021
beaucoup de déception c'est faille que
commencera le 1er août - après un petit
pincement au québec au vide on a eu de
la chance et il restait encore trois
dates de disponible sur la salle des
fêtes sinon pour décaler en 2002 c'était
super pour les personnes rencontrées la
réorganisation de leur mariage sa
compagne d'un surcoût et reste un
événement privilégié
voilà et avec la chaleur vous prendrez
bien une bonne glace mais attention pas
n'importe laquelle des glaces 100% bio
dont le producteur est associée à la
revente
c'est l' aventure dans laquelle s'est
lancée la famille morin vous allez le
voir des agriculteurs basée à mon tour
près de fougères
ils se sont associés à l'ex figure
politique arnaud montebourg le nom de la
glace
eh bien c'est la mémère reportage de nos
confrères de thé vert à rennes qu'ils
ont goûté regarder l'idée vient de
nicolas à 20 ans et un bac pro vente et
agricole en poche il rejoint
l'exploitation familiale avec l' envie
de diversifier la production la suite
s'enchaîne très vite la famille
contacter arnaud montbourg après avoir
appris dans la presse qu'il souhaite
développer la production de glace
française le laboratoire lui est
inaugurée le 13 juin
c'est là où tout se passe en fait c'est
de la bonne recette du coup voilà bah
comme là j'ai préparé du chocolat ce
matin en fait il monte à 80 6 degrés et
indécent à 20 degrés en trois heures ce
qui permet de madeline et tout ce qui
est bactéries et de pasteuriser la
recette je veux dire le la préparation
car ici au gaec du rocher nourrit les
glaces sont totalement locale le lait
provient de ce cheptel de 65 vaches et
permet la production de 3000 pau par
semaine et c'est nicolas formé par le
glacier meilleur ouvrier de france david
v smael qui élabore les parfums tout se
joue ici et c'est vrai que nous
un objectif de quelque chose de moelleux
et de goûteux en même temps et donc
nicolas il regarde ensuite c'est lui qui
va reprendre l'initiative de dire je
vais goutte à goutte et sa propre case
comment elle est ce qui a surtout donné
l'envi à la famille de se lancer c'est
le modèle économique proposé les morin
possède 51% de la société
arnaud montebourg et son associé 49% et
depuis sa création la ss à embaucher
deborah en intérim mon objectif c'était
de mettre mon territoire en avant si
j'avais à créer de l'emploi sur
l'exploitation ou sur la ss des glaces
du rocher nourrir mes collaborateurs
c'était de l'emploi local durant le
confinement la famille a produit 30
mille pauvre vendus en grande surface
sur le territoire est né en région
parisienne nicolas travaille
actuellement sur l'élaboration d'un
sixième parfum une glace caramel au
beurre salé
de quoi titiller les papilles de cet été
avec le goût de la bretagne
une bonne nouvelle dans ce grand jt des
territoires et pour toutes les
entreprises en difficulté avec cet
exemple dans la sarthe où nous allons
nous rendre maintenant
enfin un repreneur pour l'entreprise
arjowiggins célèbre usine de papier
fermé l'année dernière avec 575 salariés
qui sont restés sur la paille
l'émotion était donc très forte sur
place au moment de la nouvelle les
équipes devient lmtv sarthe était sur
place regardez c'est la bonne nouvelle
que les ex salariés d'arjowiggins à
bessé sur braye attendait depuis plus
d'un an
ce vendredi le tribunal a autorisé la
reprise du site par le groupe canadien
pas peur miles industrie une nouvelle
accueillie avec beaucoup d'émotion pour
les ex salariés réunis devant le site
un choc mais dans le bon sens du terme
j'ai dit c'est encore un fake ou quoi on
sait pas ce que y avait plein de bruit
et on n'y croyait plus et puis là-bas si
ça repart tant mieux c'est un second
souffle
je me suis dit c c c est quelqu un qui
lance une rumeur et puis après dans les
articles je voyais que les mandataires
été cités donc là j'ai dit personne
n'osera faire ça quand même donc jetée
ouest j'étais estomaqué d'autres
réalisent à peine pour moi c'était fini
ça fait drôle mais on avait l'impression
que c'était pour vrai quoi car les ex
employés se sont battus jusqu'au bout
pour que l' usine continue à vivre
la reprise est synonyme de joie mais la
prudence reste de mise
le projet de reprise du groupe canadien
envisage d'embaucher jusqu'à 240
personnes d'ici 2025
pour le moment on sait que ça sera
certainement une équipe technique qui va
remettre tout ça en route c'est un gros
paquebot à remettre en route on sait que
les salariés sont très très motivés on
le voit un peu partout et puis il ya ces
c'est plein de bonne humeur quoi une
reprise qui devenait essentiel pour ce
bassin du sud-est sarthois dont
l'économie est impacté par cette
fermeture alors jacques lacoste le maire
de bessé sur braye a accueilli non sans
émotion mais avec prudence cette bonne
nouvelle alors que depuis plus d'un an
il se battait pour sauver les usines
quand je voyais tous ces gens autour de
moi cela m'a pris souvent souvent au
coeur et j'avoue que j'ai souvent eu des
larmes aux yeux parce que quand je
voyais le sort de ces salariés qui
attendaient pas
je ne pouvais que partager l'or lors des
treize fois à ce jour sur les quelques
700 salariés qui travaillaient dans
l'usiné d'arjowiggins 180 ont retrouvé
un cdi
voilà un problème peut en cacher un
autre
loin des préoccupations liées aux copies
de 19 à présent cette attention au
moustique tigre à toulouse la brigade du
tigre
il s'appelle comme ça composé
d'habitants du quartier de rangueil a
installé des pièges pour lutter contre
sa propagation
la brigade du tigre donc veut davantage
sensibiliser les personnes à agir en
collectif car la lutte contre le
moustique tigre aura un effet si tout le
monde s'y met tout le voisinage adopte
les bons gestes comme ne pas laisser de
l'eau stagnante bien entendu dans son
jardin au niveau de la municipalité de
toulouse 10 bornes anti moustique tigre
sont installés dans toute la ville à
proximité des crèches notamment et
peuvent capturer jusqu'à 8000 moustiques
femelles par mois toutes les
explications avec nos confrères de vie
occitane et sur place le moustique tigre
est bien de retour à toulouse
implanté depuis 2010 dans la ville il
est là depuis la mi avril cette année et
la brigade du tigre a composé
d'habitants du quartier de rangueil a
installé les pièges pour lutter contre
sa propagation tel au piège alarme c1
un instrument si on peut dire un
dispositif qui attire les femelles les
femelles se met sur ce petit plongeoir
elles ont besoin d'un support pour pour
prendre elles pondent apeuré près 100
200 euros par compte
les oeufs éclosent les larves descente
dans le piège et ne peuvent pas remonter
ce qui fait que à chaque fonte on
élimine 200 e
l'année dernière la brigade du tigre
avait commandé près de 200 pièges pour
les personnes qui le souhaitaient mais
cette année la brigade veut passer à
l'étape supérieure et favoriser les
personnes à agir en collectif un
moustique quand il pond ses oeufs
les produits de la ponte ne se déplace
pas au delà de 150 m donc si vous faites
quelque chose et pas votre voisin ça
sert à rien au niveau de la municipalité
de toulouse 100 sites prioritaires ont
été sélectionnés parmi les parcs les
crèches et écoles pour lutter contre ces
nuisibles avec des pièges et notamment
l'installation de bornes anti moustiques
par le biais d'une bonbonne de co2 va
diffuser des composés qui vont être
amenés à attirer la femelle moustique et
qui vont la piéger dans un système de
soufflerie et d'aspirations qui vont
permettre de capter le moustique et les
effets de cette borne sont positives
dont capture que des femelles ces salles
qui pique donc qu'on peut arriver
jusqu'à 8000 capture mensuel donc par
ben oui ça peut aller très vite
donc là sur toulouse on est un tout
petit peu moins ce n'est pas long
camargue mais sans se rapproche quand
même de ce genre de chiffres 10 bornes
anti moustique tigre sont installés dans
toute la ville à proximité des crèches
et d'autres lieux sont étudiés pour les
installer prochainement
voilà à présent dans ce grand jt des
territoires nous allons nous rendre en
bretagne du côté de saint brieuc
certaines plages là bas sont pollués par
l'apparition de micro plastiques et
l'association vivarmor nature à réaliser
des tests les résultats font apparaître
une pollution importante
mathilde krim nerfs pour la chaîne tébéo
nos confrères sur place vous explique ce
qui s'est passé
les plages de la baie de saint brieuc
font partie des plus polluées au micro
plastiques d'europe c'est ce que révèle
une étude de l'association vivarmor et
plus particulièrement dans l'anti signac
et sur cette plage à lyon ici c'est une
des stations on a le plus de micro
plastiques en b soit les micro
plastiques proviennent de dégradation de
macro déchets soit ils viennent et ils
ont été intégrés à l'environnement
directement sur cette taille par exemple
quand on fait une machine de lessive de
vêtements synthétiques la pêche et
l'aquaculture en général donc utile et
culture et autres avec leurs équipements
qui peuvent se dégrader force d'être
utilisé tous ces plastiques pourrait se
retrouver piégé en quelque sorte dans
cette fonderie en fait la morphologie
fait que c'est en passant zone abritée
et du cou
ventilé cours m'a donc ça pourrait
expliquer une accumulation denis
progressive de huit ans et demi après
les algues vertes
ce pêcheur découvre donc une nouvelle
source d'inquiétude les micro plastiques
ça nous inquiète ça peut être pas de
temps sur le produit une fois que dès
qu'on travaille surtout sur nous sur nos
vies valent sur les coquillages qui sont
filtreurs on va surtout parler pour nous
de la coquille saint jacques pour
décortiquons avec des avec des taux
vraiment qu'ils sont surveillés
régulièrement au niveau des analyses et
c'est vrai que si un jour le micro
plastiques est vraiment impactant sur
sur ces coquillages là on pourra plus
faire leur métier comme on fait
actuellement
selon l'association vivarmor 80% des
micro plastiques sont de couleur bleu et
noir ceux qui suggèrent une faible
diversité dans les sources de pollution
elle espère pouvoir poursuivre ses
investigations dans les mois sans doute
voilà c'est un mouvement international
qui se portent comme vous allez le voir
jusque dans les rues de bastia en corse
c'est une marche dont l'objectif est de
lever le voile sur les violences et les
abus sexuels
la parole se libère là bas aussi et
munis de pancartes les victimes
dénoncent et crie à l'injustice
en tête de cortège les organisatrices
qui ont livré des témoignages
bouleversants vous allez le voir comme
le montre ce reportage de nos confrères
de via pas aisé sur place c'est
magnifique de voir tout ce tout ce monde
qui est venu nous soutenir
il ya probablement des victimes qui sont
venus au camp des non victimes des
hommes des femmes vraiment de tout âge
aussi on espérait que les gens ils se
sentent concernés et en fait c'est le
cas donc ça fait vraiment plaisir c'est
vrai qu'en corse on a toujours été et
est bercé en fait dans l'idée qu'on ne
risquez rien qu'on était à l'abri au
final c'est pas le cas et du coup ça
fait du bien de d'ouvrir les yeux aux
gens que les gens se rendent compte que
le ballon en corse on n'est pas à l'abri
comme nulle part ailleurs le but c'est
de briser les tabous et
et que les gens ils se rendent compte
que ici on a c'est le pays des valeurs
comme angie est en fait il ya juste des
tabous énorme sur des crimes pareil j'ai
vu le hca quand j'ai commencé à avoir
des jeunes filles de corse qui ont
commencé à parler je me suis dit qu'il
était temps pour moi aussi d'en parler
ça m'a donné du courage et j'avais
surtout une très forte envie de dénoncer
dénoncer ces violences dont moi-même
j'ai été victime et dont beaucoup
d'autres filles et garçons sont victimes
on n'est pas écouté nos plaintes sont
souvent classés sans suite et la plupart
du temps voilà ils se permettent de nous
faire des remarques personnelles qui
n'ont aucun rapport avec ce pour quoi on
est venu on compte pas s'arrêter là
il faut il faut il faut lever le voile
sur tout ça et à éduquer les gens très
tôt on prend maintenant la direction des
yvelines direction d'avron le domaine la
bouche du roi qui est une ex winery
parisienne et premiers domaines
professionnels viticoles de la plaine de
versailles qui va inaugurer dès ce
week-end des circuits oenologiques
il fera possible de passer deux heures
dans les vignes à quelques kilomètres de
paris
un reportage de michael elle me d'euros
pour tv 78 la chaîne des yvelines
visiter un domaine viticole dans les
yvelines sera désormais possible la
bouche du roi premier professionnel de
la plaine de versailles va inaugurer des
circuits oenologique à partir du 26 juin
le site implanté depuis 2010 est dans le
département proposera quatre à cinq
créneaux par semaine
c'était très important pour nous de
parler notre projet est d'allier le
tourisme et de fait de pouvoir expliquer
notre travail deux heures d'immersion
on vous amène dans les vignes en partant
du village qui ont fini par une
dégustation au centre du vignoble avant
de vous ramener qui qui vous permettront
au bout de deux heures d'être rentré
dans l'histoire de la bouche du roi qui
est très riche dans la plaine de
versailles et de connaître vraiment ou
si on aura les visiteurs pourront
notamment découvrir les six cépages du
domaine répartis sur 23 hectares
les guides présenteront également
l'histoire du sol argilo calcaires et
les dernières plantations du mois de
juin sur le site
ce circuit sur cette commune de 340
habitants est apprécié des élus locaux
je trouve que ça va amener un peu du
qualitatif au village et notamment un
peu de ça peut aller faire connaître un
peu ce village qui est en beau village
les yvelines et ça va montrer combien ce
département c'est s'ancrer dans l'âtre
dans la tradition on est un vieux
département à l'école mais aussi dans la
modernité dans l'avenir
ces découvertes coûtera 39 euros les
responsables espèrent attirer cet été
entre 50 et 60 personnes par semaine sur
ce domaine qui devrait produire plus de
cent cinquante mille bouteilles dès 2024
voilà tout au long de cette crise
sanitaire il a été beaucoup question d
pad justement mon invité du grand jt des
territoires c'est antoine sénanque
bonjour antoine sénanque bonjour si
réveiller alors vous êtes médecin votre
roman touchant aux choses essentielles
de la vie le personnage principal de
votre roman est médecin et justement
directeur d'un ehpad
vous êtes vous m médecin comment avez
vous vécu cette crise du coc vite 19 qui
a énormément touchés les ehpad mon gars
de médecins c'est un regard qui est
rempli de tragédie puisque dans les ai
pas particulièrement la crise a été
absolument tragique et c'est vrai que il
ya quand même vraiment une remise en
question et non pas un procès mais
une un débat absolument nécessaire à
ouvrir sur l'abandon qui a été
véritablement vécu par les patients des
ehpad et par les médecins qui
travaillent dans lesquels on a été
laissé et c'est vrai que j'ai des amis
qui dirigent des ehpad qui se sont
sentis absolument abandonné et ça je
pense que en 2020 en france
là on a quand même en principe une
armature de santé extrêmement solide
c'est pas tolérable antoine sénanque le
titre de votre roman que sont nos amis
devenus votre personnage principal va
essayer dans cet établissement pour
personnes âgées de regagner sa vie
saliha lui de regagner et de revivre
autour d'une valeur importante
l'amitié c'est important l'amitié moi
l'amitié c'est le sujet qui m'inspire le
plus moi j'adore la métier c'est là la
valeur essentielle domaine et donc j'ai
voulu justement faire un livre sur
l'amitié en mettant en contact de deux à
dix comme comme j'aime les voir c'est
pour moi il ya deux types dan il ya les
secouristes c'est à dire les amis sur
lesquels on peut compter
et puis les compagnons c'est à dire les
amis sur lesquels on veut pas compter
mais les amis avec lesquels on s'amuse
pierre morange et entouré d'amis qui
vont essayer de faciliter sa vie parce
que il est confronté à des problèmes
assez important et en essayant de
faciliter s'agit finalement ils ont
aggravé énormément la situation et tout
ça débouche donc sur des situations
comiques drôle et qui je pense sont
assez dépendantes est utile en ce moment
dans ses livres que vous faites
antoine sénanque est ce que ces
situations que vous coucher sur le
papier viennent de votre métier de
neurologues car vous êtes neurologue et
vous pratiquez la neurologie dans la vie
est ce que ça vient de cette exploration
du cerveau que vous faites
à l'origine ces spécialités un peu
difficile 12 et en 2020 hong
dit pas de grandes maladies
neurologiques on aime on suit on donne
des traitements pour les symptômes et il
n'ya pas pour les grandes maladies
neurologiques de guérison possible
donc je pense qu un neurologue a aussi
besoin particulièrement parmi toutes les
spécialités et bien de d'ouvrir un petit
peu les les perspectives sur des choses
joyeuses amical est optimiste et et moi
j'ai besoin de cette écriture et besoin
de parler de l'amitié de l'amour voilà
antoine sénanque je conseille votre
roman que sont nos amis devenus chez
grasset merci d'avoir été l'invitée du
grand jt des territoires merci suivi du
voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce grand jt
des territoires sur les chaînes de
télévision locales et régionales de la
tnt et sur tv5 monde et on se retrouve
bien sûr pour la prochaine édition
bon courage à tous au revoir
[Musique]